no
[Música]
en su régimen hicieron todo lo que
pudieron para que los inspectores no
encontrarán nada absolutely nacen pero
tenían ninguna prueba
y quienes eligieron vivir a la legación
podrían verse forzados a vivir con miedo
hemos tomado la decisión lanzaremos la
invasión
septiembre de 2001
[Música]
eeuu se alista para la guerra el
presidente george w.bush reúne a sus
principales asesores en materia de
seguridad
el secretario de defensa acude con su
brazo derecho
un tal paul wolfowitz
los adjuntos como yo no debíamos asistir
pero tomo la palabra frente al
presidente diciéndole irak hay que
aprovechar esta oportunidad para
movilizarse en irak y el presidente se
volteó hacia su consejera para la
seguridad nacional y le preguntó quién
es él ella le explicó que era el
secretario adjunto para la defensa y él
le contestó pues díganle que se calle no
quiero volver a escuchar eso estamos
concentrados en afganistán
dos semanas más tarde el congreso
desbloqueo finalmente el nombramiento de
john negroponte como embajador en la onu
mientras tanto wolfowitz y sus consortes
lograron imponer a irak como tema de
preocupación para el presidente desde su
primer día en el cargo a negroponte le
asignan una tarea inesperada
me pidieron reunirme con el
representante permanente de irak
nation
el embajador iraquí en la onu para decir
las cosas
se transmitieron puntos músculos para
comunicarle
lo que significaban en pocas palabras 28
si piensa aprovecharse tan sólo un
segundo de nuestra preocupación habitual
en afganistán es que existen
tenga la certeza de que tomaremos
medidas muy fuertes contra ustedes
y un mensaje amenazante era octubre de
2001 y dicha administración ya pensaba
en irak y francamente creo que trata de
culpar a irak de lo que sucedió
la advertencia de estadounidense fue
retomada por la prensa pero pasó un poco
desapercibida el mundo observa a
afganistán donde los talibanes han sido
expulsados del poder por estados unidos
y sus aliados locales pero tras
bambalinas la administración busca e
inició a serios preparativos el año 2002
acaba de empezar cuando en langley en la
sede de la cia sand fadi se encargado de
organizar un equipo
la decisión de invadir irak ya había
sido tomada por el presidente de eeuu
y quiero decir esto no era tal vez
invadiremos y encontramos armas de
destrucción masiva
esa decisión fue tomada invadiremos y mi
trabajo consistía en conducir un primer
equipo al lugar de los hechos para
preparar la invasión a irak
fadi si sus hombres son los primeros
estadounidenses que llegan al territorio
iraquí durante el verano de 2002 mucho
antes que las fuerzas especiales son tan
solo 8 al llegar pero con el paso de los
meses el equipo crece 50 agentes
ubicados en kurdistán recorren todo el
país buscando armas de destrucción
masiva
hacia el verano de 2002 para mí no había
ninguna duda de que estábamos planeando
una invasión
a pesar de todo colin powell y yo
tratamos de evitar la guerra y buscamos
una resolución de la onu
en especial francia alemania y rusia se
oponen a participar en una guerra sin
razón válida la resolución negociada con
eeuu permite ganar tiempo y hacer
regresar a los inspectores de la onu a
irak para verificar si saddam hussein
tiene o no armas de destrucción masiva
infortunadamente para el vicepresidente
estadounidense dick cheney
nos dijo muchas cosas y entre ellas lo
cual me hizo saltar
no ayudaremos en desacreditar los a
favor del desarme pero el sentido era
nos dimos cuenta más tarde que si no
encuentren y no desentierran esas armas
entonces nosotros mismos
hans blix y su equipo de inspectores
recorren irak visitan sitios sospechosos
e incluso los palacios del rais sin
encontrar ningún rastro de las famosas
armas y las armas químicas no son
mermelada dejan rastro entonces debe
haber archivos pero cuando fuimos a los
palacios de sadam durante una de
nuestras inspecciones revisamos todos
los inspectores abrieron las neveras
después sólo encontraron mermelada y no
armas químicas muy bajo aunque las
mermeladas
para los franceses es demasiado eeuu
trata de legitimar su muy probable
guerra mediante una nueva resolución de
la onu pero parís amenaza con usar su
derecho al veto
el momento de la ruptura unas cuantas
semanas más tarde dominique de bilbao lo
expresa con determinación frente a las
naciones unidas
es un viejo país sin francia no cumplen
ya lo de un día un continente como en
europa que sabe todo lo que les debe a
los combatientes de la libertad llegados
de eeuu y del
terrorismo
quieren actuar decididamente con todos
los miembros de la comunidad
internacional
nuestra capacidad de construir juntos
mejor
ya saben nunca se aplaude era el consejo
de seguridad y
el aplauso fue espontáneo fue aplaudido
espontáneamente
sentimos que algo pasaba
es cierto que ese día francia fue la voz
de una gran parte del mundo y no es poca
cosa
y ese discurso magnífico fue percibido
en washington como una cachetada con un
clic
colin powell me convocó a su oficina
diciéndome o dijo
queridos traté de ayudarlo para defender
la razón frente a los demás
uso
es decir el vicepresidente de jane es
decir el ministro de defensa
pero ahora estoy carbonizado
débil
nunca nos dijo algo que no fuese cierto
para mí no hubo sorpresa con dominique
débil para hay que reconocerle eso tuvo
el coraje de decirnos las cosas
en la administración bush dos bandos se
oponen los que querían la guerra
liderados por dick cheney y el
secretario para la defensa donald
rumsfeld y los partidarios de la
negociación conducidos por colin powell
y su equipo lawrence wilkerson recibió
un día la visita de un coronel
desencajado
dijo creen que ustedes son espías espías
pero espías para quien
no aprecian a su jefe el secretario
powell
ok de acuerdo me dice que ya no podemos
hablar nos queremos hablar me dijo el
coronel necesitamos hablarnos pero el
secretario de defensa nos dijo que no
podíamos
entendí que una parte de ello si no todo
era que hablaban de siria irak y
hablaban de irán y preparaban planes de
guerra para esos países pero no querían
que nos enterásemos
[Música]
a finales de enero de 2003 colin powell
abandonó la casa blanca para reunirse
con su adjunto en el séptimo piso del
departamento de estado
george bush acaba de informarlo tendrá
que pronunciar un discurso ante el
consejo de seguridad de la onu para
presentar las pruebas estadounidenses la
oficina del vicepresidente acaba de
entregarle un expediente completo
me dijo francamente
pero parece [__] entonces si de los
próximos días a la cia para verificar
cada información indicada para estar
seguro de que tiene sentido
powell acompañado por su fiel jefe de
gabinete pasa la semana en langley donde
el director de la cia george tenet pone
a disposición sus agentes
cuando llegue allá no había ningún
experto de inteligencia conmigo para
decirle a george tenet que se fuera al
[__] sabes estás equivocado georges lo
siento déjame explicarte porque ahí
fracasé fui a la cia y viví allá durante
seis días y seis noches
mi equipo estaba constituido por un
redactor del discurso leon davidson
por un barrido la web chrome un antiguo
miembro del consejo nacional de
inteligencia y george el primer día se
niega a darme acceso a los computadores
de la fia entonces llamé a barry y le
dije barry aún tienes tu carnet de
acceso y me dijo no sé tratemos se sentó
frente al equipo se conectó y bingo aún
tenía las autorizaciones entonces le
digo no hay dedo medio para tener
estábamos conectados al computador
durante una semana cada información fue
desmenuzada mucha fue descartada por el
equipo del secretario de estado el día
previo al discurso frente al consejo de
seguridad
powell tenet y sus equipos se reunieron
en nueva york esta vez en el último piso
de representación estadounidense en la
onu el secretario de estado lee por
primera vez el discurso completo en voz
alta
esto
[Música]
es
y estoy sentada a su izquierda
pennetta a su derecha
se voltea hacia george tenet y le dice
george me garantizas que todo lo que
está en esta presentación es lo mejor
que tienes
tenedlo mira y le dice si te lo juro gay
y powell le dijo más te vale porque
estará sentado atrás mío mañana frente a
las cámaras
[Música]
sadam y su régimen hicieron todo lo que
pudieron para que los inspectores no
encontraran nada
me inclino hacia dominique débil para le
digo aquí en este salón nadie cree en lo
que dice y tal vez ni él mismo estaba
sentado del otro lado de la mesa y
recuerdo haber sido muy escéptico
sobre lo que escuchaba porque no
correspondía en nada con la experiencia
es que bautizamos todo lo que nuestras
fuentes relataron sobre estas
instalaciones móviles aquí pueden ver
laboratorios móviles montados en
camiones y vagones sabemos que se
asemejan en fermentadores a que se
asemejan los reservorios las bombas los
compresores y otras piezas pero de dónde
salió eso quién se lo dijo
y porque nosotros no encontramos nada de
eso
estamos aquí todo el día todos los días
mes tras mes tratando miles de fuentes
y no encontramos nada lo que le puedo
asegurar es que no había ninguna
intención de engañar a nadie
no había voluntad de engañar y siempre
actúa a partir de informaciones cerradas
e incorrectas
y dice que es una mancha indeleble en su
carrera
no es evidencia
no me arrepiento de nada y él se
arrepiente
la administración bush no se queda
solamente con el discurso de colin
powell sus consejeros principales tratan
de convencer a sus interlocutores en la
más mínima ocasión yo recuerdo una
reunión de los ministros de la otan con
rupert llegó con fotos diciendo tengo la
prueba de que los iraquí se están
preparando para lanzar misiles
potencialmente nucleares pero justo
antes de que yo me fuera nuestros
servicios de inteligencia me habían dado
fotos precisas de nuestros satélites
franceses de ese mismo lugar bajo un
ángulo un poco diferente y en aquel
momento hasta que las fotos y le dije
diseño secretario de estado miranda son
silos de trigo hubo un silencio en esa
reunión estaba furioso se sentía y se
veía
y ahí sacó profetas y dijo ve ahí
adentro hay virus de no sé qué que
obtuvimos en irak
lo que evidentemente también era falso
le había preguntado a mi vecino era un
italiano creo que estaba a mi lado yo
digo que algo de amor pues debo caer
para que veamos último lo que escribí él
está vivo con jugar
los dirigentes de la cia se basaron en
el testimonio de una fuente de los
servicios alemanes bautizada curval que
nunca pudieron interrogar los alemanes
cuestionaban sus acusaciones
y en febrero de 2003 no podía salir de
la sombra y afirmar que no había ningún
arma podría decir adelantamos a
setecientas inspecciones que no
encontramos nada y son profesionales
persiste una pregunta si sadam husein se
deshizo de cualquier arma de destrucción
masiva en especial química por qué no
aportar pruebas le temía a irán' pensaba
que irán aprovecharía para dominarlo es
por eso
pero para washington poco importan los
hechos tumbar a saddam hussein se volvió
una obsesión
a esta hora las fuerzas estadounidenses
y la coalición están iniciando la
operación militar para desarmar a irak
liberar a su pueblo y defender al mundo
contra un gran peligro
como la guerra empezó anoche pero una
nueva fase de empezar
los misiles estadounidenses cayeron en
tres barrios en especial el barrio
presidencial de sadam
un bombardeo en el corazón de bagdad hoy
la ciudad se volcó a la guerra escribe
del ayer en washington el día de la
caída de bagdad te recuerdo estoy en la
casa blanca el director de europa me
dice sabe tomará tiempo para que eeuu
perdone a francia y yo respondo sabe
tomará tiempo antes de que el mundo
perdona eeuu
me levanto y salgo
[Música]
ah
i
[Música]
ah